from the White House an acknowledgment
that where the three objects shot down
over North America since Friday came
from was still unknown we do not assess
that these most recent objects posed any
direct threat to people on the ground
and we are laser focused on confirming
their nature and purpose including
through intensive efforts to collect
debris in the remote locations where
they have fallen Kirby added that the
U.S military had recalibrated radar
sensitivity to track smaller low-speed
objects it's not clear if that's why
more were being detected or if there had
been a sudden influx of such objects the
Canadian Prime Minister however
suggested a connection between the three
objects intercepted since Friday well I
think obviously there is some sort of
pattern in there the fact that we are
seeing this uh in a significant degree
over the past week is a cause for uh
interest and and
close attention which is exactly what
we're doing on Sunday the head of NORAD
or the North American Aerospace Defense
command raised eyebrows with an answer
to a question about whether the origins
of the objects may be extraterrestrial I
haven't ruled out anything uh at this
point but on Monday the White House
while still not ruling anything out had
this to say there is no again no
indication of aliens or extraterrestrial
activity with these recent takedowns the
US says the three objects shot down were
at a lower altitude to the Chinese
balloon shot down in early February and
all three had different appearances and
didn't appear to have any means of
propulsion just moving with prevailing
winds at the state department the U.S
deputy secretary of state addressed
relations with China we are open to
dialogue when it is in our interest to
do so and we believe the conditions are
right but Sherman said she had nothing
to announce about a potential meeting
between Secretary of State Anthony
blinken and his Chinese counterpart at
the Munich security conference later
this week shambertansi Al Jazeera
Washington